we're celebrating true gooders with a
little surprise take a look
hi my name is steph francis and i'm the
founder executive director at prodigy
ventures and practice coffee house
greetings from denver colorado this is
prodigy coffee house welcome we are a
craft coffee house apprenticeship for
young adults who are disconnected from
traditional school and work structures
they enter into a paid apprenticeship
for one to two years and they're
studying the craft of coffee but really
they're building a foundation to be
leaders in the city so we're really
excited about how this model has
potential to help rebuild the economy
hi my name is emilia from denver
colorado here at prodigy coffee house i
am the current operations manager here
and i started as an apprentice in cohort
one i was one of the first so it's been
an incredible journey i just want to say
to steph thank you for everything from
the bottom of my heart everybody here
appreciate you so much and we are so
blessed to have somebody like you in our
lives
[Music]
we got presents
hey drew this is steph we love the gift
that you sent thank you so much the drew
barrymore sweatshirt is being worn by
eugene one of our apprentices and we
love our gift card we're just so
appreciative of this opportunity to
be with you and to get to tell a little
bit about our story at prodigy
to all the true gooders out there thank
you
[Music]